What the word flip flop flopper,
uh,
denotes,
is the fact that people want to be
elected so bad.
They want this power so bad that they'll
say anything to get it.
And all you gotta do is watch some of
these politicians.
And my God,
it,
it is,
oh,
poops up.
They're just jumping right across the
board and they're all doing it.
They're all doing it on the democratic
side.
I think that there probably,
you'll see a little more consistency
with Dennis percentage,
but he's got other problems.
He's,
he's liberal,
uh,
on politics as usual and the liberal
side,
but he's the best of the bunch.
And,
and so on the other side,
but you see them,
they change.
Now it's very important to realize that,
and I'll say this about,
uh,
Edwards,
you know,
Edwards voted for the war and I find him
extremely sincere about the fact of,
uh,
of w w the mistake he made.
And so I really take his sincerity
straightaway.
That flip floppy,
no,
not for me.
Edwards was not flip fucking,
he was informed by experience and that
we all are.
And that's the advantage I bring to the
presidency.
I'm informed by experience and I've got
a lot more experienced than all the
others put together.